this is a dog in 1995's Toy Story it was
a staggering achievement at the time put
the detail in the fur just isn't there
compare that to this cat in Toy Story 4
the difference is clear but getting from
that dog to this cat required a lot of
innovation in between Pixar forever
changed animation in 1995 with Toy Story
the first full-length computer animated
movie with Toy Story 4 it's proving that
it's far from done changing the game
[Music]
between 1995 and 2019 Pixar's made 21
feature-length films four of those being
Toy Story movies when Toy Story was
first released in 1995 nobody had ever
seen anything like it before and in
order to bring it to life the animators
had to do some unbelievable things and
one of the most important factors in how
Pixar makes its magic happen involves
rendering rendering saves the computer
image to the perfect finished image or
video frame with lighting and motion
effects in order to render Toy Story the
animators had 117 computers running 24
hours a day each individual frame could
take from 45 minutes to 30 hours to
render depending on how complex there
are a total of 114 thousand 240 frames
to render throughout the movie there are
over 77 minutes of animation spread
across 1561 shots they had to invent a
new software called render man to handle
all this footage these guys are
professionals they're the best according
to producer Jonas Rivera if they had to
today they could render Toy Story faster
than you could watch the entire movie
however the complexity of Toy Story 4
means it can take 60 to 160 hours to
render one frame and there were a lot of
limitations for instance at this time
Pixar hadn't quite figured out how to
fully animate human characters animating
clothes was time consuming so you'll
notice a lot of shots of hands and feet
in the movie from a toys perspective
additionally they would sometimes choose
not to fully like characters so you
wouldn't see any missing details more on
lighting characters and fully clothing
them later when Toy Story 2 came around
in 1999 they had some time to work out
some of the kinks
especially with 1998 a bug's life in
between the two movies in this sequel
you'll be able to see more visible fully
formed human characters one key thing
the animators were starting to figure
out here to help them tackle humans
smoothness which they got practice on in
a bug's life here you can see the
improvement in just a few years they
wouldn't be ready to have a fully human
cast
until 2004 The Incredibles but before
mastering humans they stepped into
fantasy with 2001's monsters Inc in
Monsters Inc they tackled fur head on
her is hard to animate whether
computer-generated or stop motion this
is because it involves animating
thousands or even millions of individual
parts of a character's body in the VFX
world characters are designed then
rigged by adding points of movement
which can then be manually manipulated
while limbs are typically manual based
on the scene something like fur needed
to be automated sin to would take a lot
more time to move each individual strand
of hair a bug's life which centers on
insects didn't have a need for fur and
there is a dog in Toy Story but as
you'll notice it's pretty smooth as is
the dog in Toy Story 2 Sully who's tall
and covered head to toe and fur has over
1 million hairs on his body but it's not
just how it looks the animators had to
get all of those hairs to move to do
this they create a program called
simulation in which certain elements
that are too difficult to hand animate
our motion simulated see instead of
looking at Sully's hair as a whole they
looked at each strand as a distinct
particle they had to look at every kind
of force that would act on those
particles and thus how each one will
move in reaction to them so if you want
to work at Pixar you might need to know
physics
they also found real-world fur on
different animals like llamas for
reference by doing this they found the
best way to make hair look and move
realistically is to clump it together
monsters inc laid down the technical
foundation which allowed Pixar to have
over 250 furry monsters in the sequel
monsters University the tools at their
disposal also help them create fur on
animals seen in ratatouille and up the
moss on the submarine from this scene in
Finding Nemo and the grass on the ground
in
Pixar's next movie 2003's Finding Nemo
also required the animators to create
things they'd never put on screen before
this time they had to figure out how to
make a movie set largely underwater once
again science and real-world references
would help them out just as they did
with hair they broke down the water as
much as they could to get it right
according to director of photography
Danielle Feinberg they started with a
real life underwater clip recreated it
in the computer and broke it down to
find the most essential elements the
biggest one light and how it travels
through water the light they created
affected both the visibility and the
color of the film's elaborate underwater
world and while they need science to
animate certain elements of a movie
there are times where they can use
artistic license for instance they made
the water in Sydney Harbor look fairly
green to fit the mood of the scene in
reality it would not be that color once
the environment was created they had to
populate the world perhaps the most
challenging sea creature they had to
create was Hank the octopus from the
2016 sequel finding dory it was
literally impossible for them to put
Hank and Nemo and you can see why
creating just one scene with him
supposedly took about two years
character supervisor Jeremy Talbot
explained that they had to break down an
octopus and piece it back together again
which sounds a lot like how Pixar
mastered fur and water
one thing they discovered was that
octopus tentacles don't bend but almost
unfurl and engineers spent six months
just getting the curve of one of his
tentacles right and this was even before
they mastered his camouflage and his
Pixar got better at developing the
natural world
it also improved on the man-made world
by the time 2006 as cars came around
Pixar had about 1,000 times the
computing power it did on Toy Story cars
gave the animators a chance to hone
their skills creating metal surfaces as
they did with the water in Finding Nemo
they took time to make the light reflect
off Lightning McQueen those metal
surfaces would then be rusted up and
seen in 2008 Zwolle often considered one
of Pixar's most visually stunning works
then when ratatouille rolled around in
2007 Pixar combined its ability to work
with fur from monsters ink and with
water and Finding Nemo to display wet
fur
lighting is one of the most important
factors in making CG animation look real
it takes a lot of rendering time to get
it right and it's not just one or two
lights we're talking about this one shot
alone in ratatouille contained 230
lights but that's nothing jump ahead to
2017 s Coco when Miguel enters the land
of the dead he's laying his eyes on
about eight million lights and even with
a movie as visually ambitious as this
one something as simple as clothes could
be the biggest challenge a lot of the
characters that wore clothes in Coco
were actually skeletons the animators
found that while simulating clothing the
cloth would often get caught between
individual bones creating a wedgie of
sorts for this it implemented a
technique called continuous collision
detection which allowed the animators to
spot the clothes getting caught even at
moments where it was difficult to notice
a year later when the long waited
Incredibles to came out they were back
to working with humans skin bones and
all there was a 14-year gap between the
two Incredibles movies and the benefits
of improved technology actually allowed
them to make Jack Jack look even cuter
than he did in the first movie all of
these movies would eventually lead to
Toy Story for 24 years after the
original was released it seemed like
this sequel is trying to do a lot of
things the original just couldn't the
differences couldn't be more stark while
Toy Story used a 1.8 5 to 1 aspect ratio
Toy Story 4 expanded to two point three
nine to one so what you saw went from
this to this now that Pixar had figured
out how to put fur on one character and
then hundreds more it could make the
animals in this movie I popping
fans pointed out that a cat in a clip
for the movie looks 100% real
compare that with SIDS dog in the
original if you really want to know how
far Pixar has come even just compare how
much different it looks from the cat and
cocoa in the same vein creating stuffed
animals covered in fur was not the
challenge at once was and it allowed
Pixar to give duckie and bunny starring
roles in addition rain scenes are not
easy to animate just like with the water
and Finding Nemo the animators did a
physic centered frame-by-frame analysis
of raindrops
luckily they've done enough creating
rivers in the good dinosaur that
bringing a torrential downpour to life
was a little less challenging like with
Jack Jack and Incredibles - the
animators used sequels as an excuse to
improve upon their classics they didn't
just give Bo Peep a new outfit they're
also able to make her look like a much
more convincing doll years of perfecting
shiny surfaces allowed them to really
bring out Bo's porcelain skin to
effectively light this material the
director of photography referenced
lighting of female characters in movies
made from the 1930s through the 1960s
the team also realized they couldn't use
square lights on Bo only circular lights
without sharp edges would reflect well
on porcelain Toy Story 4 also gave Pixar
a chance to do something surprising go
back to basics look no further than for
ki there are no tentacles no fur no
shiny surfaces here just a plastic fork
but he couldn't be more real and Pixar
isn't slowing down anytime soon in fact
they're moving onward literally
you